presenting the award to some Renier is
Stephanie Allen an accomplished film
producer who has been an advocate for
visionary filmmakers for more than 20
years her films include Hustle & Flow
something new beyond the lights and dear
white people oh my goodness this is so
fun I love beginnings it's a it's a
magical time it really is there's
electricity in the air
there's the infinite possibilities the
buzz of all that and I love a beginner's
mind because you can come up with things
that no one else has really thought of
and and and change the way for everybody
coming behind you so so today is a
beginning and and it doesn't mean that
you've just started writing I mean the
scripts that we read were so good I know
that all of you have been writing for a
for a long time and and have rewritten
these scripts many many times you'd have
to - best 7,000 other writers so
congratulations it's very exciting this
is the beginning of your professional
career compensation accolades and
hopefully it will go on and on at like
Rodrigo I will just say please hold on
to that voice that distinctive voice
that you have now that that brought you
here tonight it's been a privilege to
serve on this committee I love it
I've spent my career producing
first-time writers first-time writer
directors
I run the LA Film Festival so I am all
about diversity and unique voices and
and women's voices so when I read free
agent I was like wonderful a brand new
woman's voice out there this is
fantastic I cannot wait to meet her
I was cocksure was written by a woman
because there are - yes - amazing
realized the
male characters that are nuanced and and
there are even different ages and they
do they do man stuff like like play
basketball and and speak in front of
boardrooms and and sign athletes for
multi-million dollar contracts and and
take younger lovers a guy couldn't have
written that but then I met Sam and I
hope I don't embarrass him by saying Sam
you're one of us and by that I mean you
are smart you are talented you're humble
you're grateful you're not afraid of
showing emotion you know you give praise
words do to your wife and to your kids
and I just realized for once that was I
was happy to be wrong because the only
thing better than having more unique
voices and voices from from women
writers is having guys write about us
too
so I'd love to congratulate and bring up
Sam
Rainier
hello thank you so much that was amazing
and thank you to all of you for being
here and also for forgiving me or
forgetting I should say when I lose it
in about two and a half minutes so it
didn't happen and it won't happen okay
I would like to thank I have a lot of
thank yous to the Academy to everyone as
a part of the nickel committee to Joan
and to Greg to the luminaries on the
nickel fellowship committee this changed
my life to CBS Films who pursued the
script and acquired it let's make a
movie
- my manager Scott for his guidance and
let's call it encouragement he's gonna
hit me later - my family - my dad who
taught me about work ethic - my mom
taught me to love story mom I know I'm
not John Irving yet but I'm working on
it - my kids who inspired the script
it's past your bedtime
go to sleep no more songs no more books
no more glasses of water go to bed now I
know you are awake and lastly to my wife
I need to apologize this is not the
speech I told you that I was going to
give a few years ago we came into a
bottle of champagne and I decided that I
was gonna save it for the day that I
sold my first screenplay which is always
a great idea because we know the
universe always rewards hubris if we've
learned nothing from Greek tragedy
that's the primary lesson and I took
that bottle I put it back in my fridge
and I looked at it almost every day for
the next seven years which is actually
just as long as it sounds and and we we
didn't talk about it because it's a
strange thing I don't know if you've
ever had a complicated relationship with
an inanimate object but it's not all
it's cracked up to be
and this past summer in June when I was
putting it in a box to move it to its
fourth home I looked at it and I thought
this is lunacy and this is crazy and I
thought I'm talking to a bottle so I put
it in a box and I put it in the truck
and when I got there one of the first
things I did
open the box and I thought you know we
got a bottle in the fridge or a little
spoil and and I open the box and was
gone and I knew immediately that tie it
thrown it away and I thought she forgot
she forgot what it was and then I
thought you know she didn't forget you
remembered and she thought I'm gonna put
him out of his misery I was like you
know what I appreciate that
that's really really sweet take notes if
you're dating a writer just like just
pull the plug on him and I I opened the
fridge and there was and this is the
losing a part so this is for you
who believed in me on the days I didn't
believe in myself congratulations you
deserve it I love you thank you